Для зривання своя технологія.
Щоб не пошкодити нічого рослині,
палець один вказівний сюди – раз.
Раз. Так от зривається.
Це в нас «голова» йде.
І за годинниковою стрілкою [закручуємо].
Кожне колінце — це від листка до листка.
На кожному колінці потрібно за
годинниковою стрілкою підкручувати на шпалери.
Це господарство – це вже наш сімейний бізнес.
Вже третє покоління.
Я і син мій продовжуємо
це фактично з 1980 року.
Займаємось овочами закритого ґрунту
в основному і відкритого ґрунту.
Зараз ми приватні підприємці Баранніки,
два підприємця — він і я.
Знаходимось в Дніпропетровській області,
Покровському районі, селі Доропасове.
Колись було – Червоний Лиман.
Добропасов – це наш солдат,
який загинув під Луганськом, коли збили літак.
В його честь назвали село.
Основний напрям – огірки.
В нас і томати є, ми трошки садимо і т.д.
Що краще вдається – те і робимо.
У нас вдаються добре огірки.
Тут в нас був пустир, бур'яни були.
Ми забрали цю ділянку. Це з 2000 року.
За 2017-2018 оце ми тут щось зробили, наставили.
Тут голий степ був.
Ці наші теплиці – ізраїльський проект.
Ми їздили до них на навчання.
Навчились вирощувати і будувати.
Оце вони присилали, а ми будували.
Більше помагають іноземні зацікавлені,
ніж наші українські.
В Іспанію нас возили вчитись вирощувати.
Йдемо дивитись, як росте огірок.
Так, температура хороша. Нагрівається літом.
Літом стараємось не працювати в жару,
тому робочий день починається з 6 ранку.
Огірок росте на шпалері, ведеться, підкручується —
ми його фізично підкручуємо, садимо.
Це з 1980-х років.
Тоді не можна було приватним підприємцем бути.
І городу було 15-20 соток землі.
І комуністи не давали
розвиватись приватному господарству.
І батьки працювали.
Батько – кочегаром, а у вільний час тут.
То ж 48 годин на роботі,
а весь інший час – в теплиці.
Мама розносила пошту.
Її змушували буряки полоти.
Приїжджали з бульдозером
загортати теплиці.
Дозволено, що теплиця мала бути не більше однієї сотки.
Більше – не дозволяли.
На додачу до теплиці, батьки вирощували корів,
свиней, гусей і курей багацько.
Я це пам'ятаю. Скільки пам'ятаю –робота була завжди.
Ми гуляли. Тому що і 3 корови
і 4-5 бичків, 100 гусей, 200 курей.
І так далі, і так далі. Всіх годували.
За зарплату батькові дуже хотілось машину.
І нас троє дітей. Всіх треба годувати і одягати.
В нас були ваги з тарілками:
з одного боку – гирі, з іншого – товар.
Так ми возили торгувати, ще «жигулями».
П'ять-шість годин черги і торгівлі
в роздріб по одному-два кілограми. Торгівля «кипіла»!
З ранку до обіду. Тоді ще не було
перекупщиків – торгували напряму від себе.
На зборі урожаю в нас аж чотири бригади.
Орієнтовно на гектар потрібно вісім працівників.
Вісім, з підмінами до десяти працівників,
щоб вони могли впоратись з роботою.
Оскільки їхня робота не лише збір.
Потрібно «вести», по-пасинкувати, забрати погані листки.
У нас 15 працівників оформлено,
ми сплачуємо податки.
Кожного місяця близько 25 тисяч гривень податків.
Починалось це з Кам'янки,
хтось побачивши там теплиці приїхав звідти.
Почав створювати перші теплиці.
З дроту робили дуги, невеликі – по два метри.
Іноді по метру. І так садили.
Потім з дерева почали робити.
В нас дерев'яні старі ще є, це старі проекти.
Перший прийшов, другий повторив.
В людей все виходить. Головне є придатна вода.
Одне на одного дивляться,
і так почався ріст.
Спілкуємось, дивимось, що краще,
допомагаємо один одному, підказуємо.
Основних сортів є два.
Ми ще пробуємо, проводимо досліди
з кількома новими різними сортами
для того, щоб в майбутньому бути лідерами.
Цей сорт 12-13 років тому
був тільки номерний.
Його дослідження почалось з нас.
Ми його перевіряли.
А перед цим ми заповнювали анкети.
Які в нас вимоги до довжини, ширини,
товщини, який діаметр, смакові якості.
Про це все ми заповнювали анкети.
Для нас селекціонери з Нідерландів
вивели такий сорт.
Саме для нас. Тому що Європа
любить огірок довгоплідний.
Україна і сусідні країни
має тільки короткоплідні огірки.
У нас не йдуть на ринку довгоплідні.
Люблять маленькі,
вони й смачніші і кращі.
Сина «відвоював» у жінки.
Син пішов вчитись на плодово-овочівництво.
Дружина хотіла, щоб він поліцейським став.
Я не погодився.
Єдиний Максим в нас отримав профільну
вищу освіту по спеціальності «овочівництво».
А ми самоучки.
Була можливість йти
вчитись на інші фірми.
Він сказав: «Буду біля тебе займатись цим».
Слава Богу, що він зі мною залишився.
Особисті ставлення. Більшої любові,
ніж як господарство твоє – не даси.
Як воно нічиє – то користі не буде.
Коли воно твоє особисте,
ти ним більше переймаєшся.
Ти його дужче любиш і
більше користі  виходить.